- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is "believe", and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is "you earn success".
Over to you, Eric Thomas.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I did not become successful
with two-family household,
with the income $250,000.
I was homeless, I was knocked out,
I was kicked out of school.
I was told never to return.
I did this in the midst of trials,
in the midst of tribulations.
Nobody gave me this, I earned it.
Life wasn't a crystal stair for me.
Didn't nobody give me a network.
I earned a network.
I know Warren Buffet
because I worked my way to Warren Buffet.
I worked my way to Dag Gilbert.
I worked my way to the MBA.
I worked my way to the NFL.
Everybody say, "E, how'd
you crack the code?"
I grinded my way through the code.
That's how I cracked it.
I got up every day at three.
Monday I grind, Tuesday
I grind, Wednesday...
I don't care what the economy is doing.
I don't care who the president is.
I don't care who the governor is.
I don't care who the mayor is.
My mama ain't counting on the governor.
My wife ain't counting on the President
of the United States of America.
My wife ain't counting on the mayor.
My wife ain't counting
on the commissioner.
My wife counting on me.
When I walk out that
house, she's counting on me
to bring home the bacon.
- I've never been a big fan
of things being handed to me.
I've never enjoyed that.
I've never liked, for whatever reason,
it probably comes from my parents,
of things just being handed to me
without me having to earn it.
I always felt like I wanted
to earn where I'm at.
And so I come from a middle-class family.
My parents had connections
that I could have really used
when I was starting my business,
but when I started my first company,
I didn't use them at all.
I wanted to prove to
myself that I could do it.
I went to my banker and asked for advice
and asked for help.
That's how little I knew
about the business world.
I walked into the bank and
said, "Hey, I'm trying to build
a business, I could use some help".
They asked if I needed a loan.
I said I don't think I need a loan.
I don't know, do I need a loan?
They said well that's what banks do.
That's how ignorant I
was about the process.
But I didn't want to use
any of the connections
my parents had, people that they knew
that could have springboarded
my business forward.
If I look at now, I'm on
a personal training plan.
I've got a personal trainer that comes in
a couple times a week
and trains me and Nina.
Part of what he has us on
is a strict diet regiment.
If we hit certain goals,
then we get what he calls "re-feed days",
where we get to almost double
our calories for the day.
We're excited, we've been eating lean,
we've been preparing our
food, and we want to earn
our re-feed days, and I tell him,
Shawn, don't just give it to me.
I need to earn it.
As much as we want it, if I don't get it,
if I didn't hit the milestone,
whatever you're looking
for in your criteria,
don't do it because you
want to make me happy.
Don't do it because you
like my YouTube channel.
Don't do it for any other
reason except for the fact
that I did the work, and I earned it.
Because otherwise I don't want it.
I will give up the weekend food day
and continue to struggle until I get it.
And it's just been my mindset.
And I think it's really
helpful as an entrepreneur
to have that kind of mindset.
That you want to go out and
you want to earn your success.
There's a lot of people who
look at successful people
and they will complain that,
oh they had it handed to them,
or somebody gave them a lucky break,
or they got really lucky.
If you look at the children of rich people
and say well look at this person,
they have it all made for
them, it's so easy for them.
I feel bad for them.
I feel bad for the kids
of really rich people.
Show me the kid of a really rich person
who went off and built an
amazing company on their own.
It's not how it happens, they don't.
The struggle is part of
what gives you the strength
to go off and make amazing things.
And so stop comparing
yourself to other people
and say they have it, they've
had it handed to them,
they grew up with this and that.
It doesn't matter.
I think when you adopt that mentality,
that you take responsibility
for where you are
and that you should earn
everything that you get,
that things shouldn't be handed to you,
and they shouldn't be
handed to anybody else.
When you fully believe that,
then you put in the work,
then you don't expect handouts.
Then you want to grind and hustle
and get up every day and make
forward progress on your goal
because nobody is coming to save you.
Because there's no white
nag or no cavalry coming.
It's on you to get it done.
You need to earn your success.
So the question of the day today is
I'm curious, what are you
most proud of earning.
You put in the work, and you
earned success for something.
What are you most proud of?
Leave that in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to William Chilton.
William, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word", and taking the picture
and posting it to your Google Plus page.
I really appreciate it
man, and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- So when I was invited here
today, and they said "clever",
I said to myself, hmm, I
don't think my approach
in the industry that I am
in, the fitness industry,
would be considered clever.
Because, in this day
and age and this time,
it's a push or a trend
toward easier is better.
The easier way, the easier approach.
Five-minute abs, four-minute
abs, two-minute abs,
one-minute abs (audience laughs).
Now you're going to
think I'm making this up.
But I seen an ad the other day for a belt.
You just put it around your waistline,
and you can sit on your
computer and watch Netflix,
chat with your boyfriend or girlfriend,
donkey or whatever it is you
talk to (audience laughs),
and it will work your abs for you.
Wow, that's cool, I just sit there,
and this machine will work my abs for me.
I don't have to do one
sit-up, one crunch (mumbles).
Not one, not one.
And here I come along, old
crusty old man, 55 years old,
and I look you in the eyeballs,
point my finger in your face,
and I say fuck that (audience laughs).
Get your punk ass up off the couch
and get down to that goddamn gym.
And work for what you want.
I don't know if that will
be considered clever or not.
What do you think?
- My whole career has been
in some way or another
a struggle against my own
doubts, all along the way.
As much as people say
gosh, you're so confident,
and you're the high-performance guy
and everything else, and I'm like yeah,
but it doesn't mean I don't struggle.
As a matter of fact, I probably
put myself in situations
where I must be challenged
and I must struggle
more than any normal sane person.
I'm constantly pushing
myself, all the time,
because I evaluate struggle
as something to be honored.
It used to be struggle was something
that was truly honored by people.
They thought that was
something that built character.
something that was good.
And now we've got to be such
a convenient-driven society
that's into ease and
so much, just, I think,
an unbelievable level of entitlement
where people don't think
they have to earn it.
I was like wait, if you have a dream...
Never forget, if you knock
on the door of opportunity,
that it is work who answers.
It takes a lot of work to
achieve your bigger dreams,
to become the best you who you can be,
to serve more, to create more,
to contribute at the highest level.
Man, it's a lot of work.
- I didn't have an easy experience.
I didn't come in as a top-rated recruit.
I didn't come in with the
opportunity to play right away.
I had to earn it.
And you know what the great
honor I've ever received
as a player is?
In my fourth year and my fifth year,
I was named team captain.
That, to this day, is the
single greatest achievement
I've ever had as a football player.
Because the men in this room
chose me to lead their team.
And these were my best friends.
These were the guys that
knew that I liked to work,
that knew that I love football,
that knew that I love to play,
that knew that I wanted to be
the quarterback for Michigan.
And all the lessons that I
learned here on State Street,
and in the big house,
that's still what I bring
to practice today, and after 14 years,
I love the game more
than I've ever loved it.
But where did I learn
the love for the game?
Where did I learn to practice?
Where did I learn to compete?
It was sitting in the same chairs
that you guys are sitting in today.